there's four kind of pillars of
literature there's speed which has two
components one is the speed between when
they opt in when they get their first
message and also speed of response in
general you need to be super fast on in
terms of opt-in to the first message
also just if someone like let's say
Susie Q doesn't respond to through
messages and then day two responds you
might have a five minute window where
she's sitting in a karate practice
before she got there early where you
might be able to have the opportunity to
have that interaction and if you're not
there you miss it then you have
personalization which is do I talk to
Susie different than I talk to Dan right
you would probably as a person so we
want to make sure that the machine can
do that the third is volume volume of
reach out how many reach outs do we have
typically people call the lead once and
then say the leads the leads are bad
right the leads don't work the fourth
one that we discovered availability and
it's actually the single biggest
predictor on throughput out of any of
the four variables that means that if
you're a business and you're trying to
grow your business and you're only
available to take new clients between 9
and 12 on Fridays uh you're probably not
going to grow because it's not
convenient